all right it's the moment that at least
three people in the audience have been
waiting for
uh no i got i got a couple dozen emails
about this over the last few months
as many of you recall in late 2020
we reached a very important milestone on
our youtube channel
1 million youtube subscribers
as many of you know oh wait a sec now i
can't even reach it excuse me i don't
want to show my back to people but hold
on
here we go as many of you know when we
reached 100
000 youtube subscribers youtube sent us
this silver play
button which says david pakman show
congratulations for surpassing 100 000
subscribers
the next milestone is 1 million
subscribers for such a plaque
i have the plaque i know we're closer
we're we're beyond 1.3 million it just
takes a while to these are these are
handcrafted pieces of i don't know
it just takes a while for some reason we
now have the gold
million subscriber plaque which i am
unveiling today
here it is look at that congratulations
on one million subscribers
presented to the david pakman show so i
am going i want to thank
not just the million original
subscribers but we are now
i have to be careful the studio lights
will reflect look at that that's
horrible
um the 1.3 million subscribers now we
are closer
now to 1.5 million than to 1 million
they say that that first million is the
toughest and we've already made great
progress
on the second million and unfortunately
there's no
no more plaque until you get to 10
million that's an uphill battle
that that's uh that's a tough one but um
in all seriousness
thanks to everybody who's been with us
over the years
we are um taking a little end of march
sort of spring break because it's been a
big sprint
since the election for us and then we're
going to be back with all sorts of new
stuff and
new programming we have some ideas for
for new things we're going to be
announcing soon but there it is the
hundred thousand subscriber plaque
little very very little and then this
just
monstrous 1 million subscriber gold
plaque
i'm even thinking maybe actually of
putting it up
on our backdrop maybe just the edge of
it
like could be attached it's just
extremely heavy this is a much higher
quality plaque than the silver one okay
thanks everybody really appreciate there
it is and
on to the next million